hello there reject Nation we are going
to watch today the trailer the next one
for John Wick chapter 4 for a Bellum
alrighty guys leave a like it's the
morning
and there's Carnage coming our way
let's do this
[Music]
goes out to you Mr Wick
what I'm gonna be too regular wasn't it
yeah yeah yeah and so it begins
it's long begun let's go
it's a single combat if you win
you'll have your freedom a duel
ah yes nice
sweet
peace
more horses
not really
yeah dogs
oh
oh nice
what is that action scene
he's using traffic yeah man I've never
seen a fight like that hey they used
cars against him last time he can use
cars against them this time I just love
how no one's stopping on the road no not
there you can see my that car kept going
after a body slammed onto the hood of it
isn't that a famous roundabout I feel
like that's one of those places in the
world where they're like yeah you know
if you're slowing down or stopping
people just gonna run you over there's
always gun fights and all kinds of
bodies always mean it's locked onto the
hood of my car whenever I go through
this roundabout
um yeah this looks awesome a lot of the
way the cinematography is is really sort
of hearkening back more to the first one
in a lot of ways it's got a lot of that
neo-noir lighting to it which looks
great and we are broaching we haven't
quite got there yet
um but I think just the thing with the
dog the whole thing with the roundabout
it hasn't reached Fast and Furious level
yet where it's like there's no there's
no sense of because they still they
still care about like physics and this
yes obviously brutality but yeah is it
is it getting like really anime levels
of identity yeah I want everybody who's
a part of the fight in the subsequent
installments will then just be part of
the team yeah so it's like he's got his
horses he's got his dogs who's next we
need a cat on the team we need like a
shark or something well I mean even
there's one porn in the trailer where
he's jumping off what looks like the
third story through a window straight to
the street yeah you know he's gonna be
fine
yeah he's falling off the roof of a damn
Hotel
I I love this thing even though time to
die did it with the car flipping over or
the guys flipping mid air and he's still
shooting they're shooting like two
people here that is insane you gotta
slow the this [__] down damn yeah this
is going to be overwhelming to process
in the moment I imagine and I mean this
movie is like two hours and 45 minutes
long so this also kind of is it really
yes it is and it made me think like I
mean John Wick movies obviously belong
in the same part of the video store as
like a raid movie but two I'm wondering
if they're gonna go like full Baron doll
with this and just make it like the
ultimate like John Wick movies are
certainly operatic in their own way but
I wonder if they're going to go for that
full-on like crime drama epic along with
all their fun crazy John Wick neon stuff
that's crazy because this trailer is
only 90 seconds long I know it hints at
almost nothing
offer and two I mean you know you get
the brief flashes and stuff like that
but like to have hiroyuki Sonata in here
as well as Donnie Yen and apparently
they are going to fight each other as
well as you know dealing with Johnson
with parent doesn't last trailer I
believe yeah so I mean that's gonna be
flipping awesome not a parent from this
trailer but that's gonna be like he's
got Scott Atkins in here too
um
which uh you know just as exciting as
Donnie
I mean not just like Scott Atkins I mean
he is an action movie veteran in his own
right now too brilliant fighter too
absolutely is he's got a great
reputation especially among stunt folks
as well which is like this has to be
yeah like the stuff people's dream
project now too is like as much as they
bring in characters from the movies I
have to imagine now it's the goal of
just every stunt person ever to beat a
John Wick well the fight here is like
the it's like some kind of Hunger Games
level threat of
you know only one man left standing at
the very end of it all but because it's
it's a it's a fight to win in
competition but it's also a fight so he
can actually have some type of Freedom
245 minutes what the hell is the fifth
movie gonna be about what does it matter
there's gonna be a literal high table
that's like this huge metaphysical plane
and it all take place there yeah there's
a bunch of philosophical debates and uh
and there are things he said especially
saying right to that it seems like
perhaps the bad guys are gonna get more
of a chance to shine like yeah that one
woman who was climbing that guy stabbing
him while they were going up the
staircase and she's like
and then you know you got Donnie Yen in
here because you know I like actors like
Mark tacos and um
you know uh common sure yeah I like I
like those guys but you have players in
here who are I mean Common's like really
big but you have players this time
around who in the villain category who
you would want to have a lot of screen
time in a film like this you know it
seems like they'd probably have some
type of ominous build build with Bill
Skarsgard sure and he's a wonderful
actor so I'm gonna want some like really
rich scenes with this guy and then you
got Donnie Yen who's like an
international Superstar so you're going
to want to have some rich scenes with
that guy as well
and then you're also having returning
characters like Ian McShane and Lawrence
Fishburne so you're going to want to
have great scenes with them too so you
know drawing a Raid 2 parallels actually
a really great call because
you know like these trailers obviously
hone in on Keanu the whole time
primarily I mean you cut around to the
other people but it's primarily focusing
on Keanu Reeves where you got these
other characters and and some new actors
uh in this franchise we were like yeah I
hope they get a really have a good
amount of screen time so weirdly when
you say 2 hours and 45 minutes I'm not
like a great Transformers I'm more like
oh we might get like some actual
characters
along with all the crazy barrage of
violence and stuff like that yeah yeah
I'm looking forward to that that sounds
really cool that sounds really cool
alrighty guys oh man this is an IMAX
yeah
well
I know this looks like the kind of movie
that would be perfect to react to but oh
it's Cinema though
wait for Creed 3 but watch this it is
it's your IMAX Sophie's Choice which
IMAX experience do I want more
I got it I gotta have one yeah yeah no
no it's a cinephile you owe it to
yourself John Wick reaction oh we get
way more fused sure
but I I really I'm leaning more towards
that I think I really want to watch I
mean you're a lover of of martial arts
and Kung Fu he's gonna use nunchucks in
a way that's not gonna be stupid like
you got to see them on IMAX
that which is called Bruce Lee stupid
alrighty guys since Bruce Lee he's not
gonna hit himself in the nuts for a joke
is my point
um guys what did you think about this
John Wick chapter 4 trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to uh leave
a like subscribe and let's end this with
a
David Gandy as gentle of a spirit as you
are I hope that one day you do snap I
hope that everything you love
is taken away from you by someone and
then you see the Dark Side of David
Gandhi come out where he has to go on a
Revenge spree because that would be very
short-lived I think that you would
probably be very determined but this
would be your first album like this
pretty quick I'm pretty sure you would
jaywalk and you'd get like a ticket and
that might make you reconsider all of
your decision making that you were
headed down so David it's gonna be a
great Learning lesson for you once you
realize that revenge is not the path and
you will need financial stability in
order to maintain the things you
currently have so maybe wasting your
time on it
don't do it just don't do it
but you know make sure that uh you were
saying plus your patreon page that's the
way to secure your fealty and make sure
you're being a good human being like you
always are
because we love you God loves you
and I love you